[Music]
eggsy I saw in you but someone once saw
in me something that can't be taught the
makings of achievement being a Kingsman
is more than the clothing we wear or the
weapons we bear it's about being willing
to sacrifice for the greater good
I hope you're ready what comes next
[Music]
now the end is near and so I face the
final curtain my friend I'll say it
clear I'll state my case of which I'm
certain
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
someone's planning something major the
name the golden circle keeps coming up
fingerprints remove teeth belts news a
tattoo you made of 24 karat gold what we
supposed to do now and follow the
Doomsday protocol
let's go save the world
the Golden Circle rated-r someone's
planning something major the name the
golden circle keeps coming up
fingerprints removed teeth pals means a
tattoo you made a 24 karat gold
time is running out
rated R
[Music]
finally some service Jesus do you have
any jackets without a British god I look
kind of like Twiggy pardon me who are
you oh the names sterling Archer world's
greatest spy
you probably shouldn't tell people
you're a spy then what's the point in
being one fair enough listen I'm legally
blind got it but no I don't want to
donate what the glasses you look like my
eighth grade shop teacher charming
listen mate I'm gonna need you to leave
where did you get those oh there's this
super cool secret room you gotta check
it out already Kings been allowed in
there huh the guys who sang Louie Louie
put the gear back no excuse me no you
blind and deaf I said no or I'm done
being polite
dad being polite are you governor I see
say you a gamblin man mr. Archer well I
wrote the underground here so you tell
me well then care to engage in the most
gentlemanly of competitions Turkish oil
wrestling what no you [ __ ] a drinking
contest standard Queensbury rules which
man imbibe in a shop so this is what
passes for the world's greatest spy in
America I may need to go to and teach
him a lesson but first I'm going to draw
a knob on your face
[Music]
I see what do you do I work for Kingsman
the tailless - I must say you are really
not as I expected
yes welcome back welcome to Statesman
independent intelligence agency the
American cousins how can I help you got
a bit of us say the world situation here
say goodbye to the Kingsmen you follow
their dreams their protocol let's get
started
gotta make you one slap your mama right
there bored brains skills skipping right
it's a lasso whatever
so tell me Asya what do you do I work
for Kingsman the tailless -
I must say you are really not as I
expected this will go down in history as
the single most important movie promo of
all time
when you're promoting a movie like
season in the Golden Circle it's got to
be bigger bolder than anything that's
ever been done before go flash mob crap
Millennials Brian crap so we're about
six hours into a promotions meeting I
mean all the ideas are just crap crap
crap have been done don't want to hear
it none of this is gonna put people in
the seats come on guy out of the way
you're big enough to block out the Sun
man and that's when I had a [ __ ]
brilliant idea Golden Circle Eclipse it
was like an eclipse phanie if you look
at our target audience it makes perfect
sense I mean we have people that know
about the Sun if people know about the
moon it's where they overlap that's
where the magic happens right in order
to create a man-made solar eclipse it is
going to take a critical amount of
rocket power you know the old saying
give me a Leever big enough and I can
move the earth
well I only need to move the moon my
lever is a hundred thousand tons of
liquid hydrogen and nitrogen tetroxide
and also 22 million pounds of thrust we
weren't even sure something like this
was possible of course it's possible
it's potentially catastrophic but it's
possible is it legal I mean I couldn't
find any laws against it I think you can
get super moving the moon what people
respond they're already planning their
[ __ ] vacations around it we're
literally moving the moon you ready
absolutely come on let's get started
welcome back can save her well
I don't make you more slapping mama
right there boy
what are these big bang grenades
it's very American yeah it is read it
all if someone wanted to take out
akiza's
and they've gotta be planning something
major some kind of underworld
organization the Golden Circle
say goodbye to the Kingsmen what a bit
of us say the world situation here
we follow the Doomsday protocol let's
get started
I'm crazy about a shot
maybe one slap your mama Kings method
Golden Circle rated off September 22nd
the Kingsmen are back there saving the
world
we're from Kingsley The Statesman they
are the American cousins to the Kingsmen
house I thought I want to get
merchandising and licensing and I
thought what is the high-end American
bourbon that was good enough to join
with think we're going a Kentucky I
don't know about Foreman my brand is
perfect the product that we're creating
is a bourbon under the old Forester
umbrella old Forester Statesman really
has a pretty special flavor profile that
is unbelievably smooth I have to say
that as delicious I think a key to this
partnership is that Statesman has a real
role to play in this film
Chronicle a bit of us say the world
situation here to the Kingsmen is your
American cousins all Faceman resources
in yours
enough small tools you just make it
personal
make you wanna slap your mama right
there no I don't think that'll be
necessary
it are within the Kings montañés shop in
London maybe you've heard of us
today marks the beginning of a new age
I'm gonna show you to the Kingsmen kata
for a bit of a save the world situation
here
welcome to statesman your American
cousins will be working side massage
we've got brains skills skipping-rope
[Music]
[Music]
it's very American
manners maketh man do you know what that
means
[Music]
[Music]